here are a handful of methods that can
help you during the understand stage
I'll give you a quick overview of each
of these methods the first is 360 degree
lightning talks as Nadia mentioned 360
degree lightning talks are incredibly
useful the deliverable of the design
sprint should meet the business goals
satisfy user needs and be possible with
current or emerging technology here are
the questions that should be addressed
by anyone who gives these talks for the
business side that person should be able
to address what's profitable and
sustainable for the business in the long
run and what are the current business
needs anyone speaking to the user
experience should be able to answer what
do people need and what's delightful are
useful to the user and finally someone
should be able to speak knowledgeably to
technical concerns what's possible with
today's technology or what features can
be built now or over time lightning
talks are meant to be a quick way to
address those major concerns now of any
of these activities that you do you
should be sure to do user interviews you
want to talk to users at the beginning
of the design sprint and at the end of
the design sprint so you can validate
your work user interviews allow you to
understand the goals and the motivations
of users you might also try explaining
some of their emotions and how they feel
about existing products or about
particular features that you might want
to implement if you have existing
designs you can definitely ask a user
about them if not you could always ask a
user about a competitor's design the
interview should follow a sort of arc
like this you want to get to know the
interview at first so make them feel
comfortable and keep a conversational
tone you also want to be genuinely
interested in the person so you can ask
some starter questions just to build
rapport then you can plan your questions
accordingly so you can get at their own
stories and the journal moments in this
diagram be sure to thank the user and
wrap up with any follow-up steps if you
don't have any current user research
then you should definitely consider
going to visit actual users this would
be a field visit a field visit our field
study will let you observe how users use
similar products
or you can take note of the context in
which users use that product or service
you can also ask questions about their
behaviors their likes and interests and
their pain points or problems you might
do usability testing with them if you
have current designs or you might use
competitor designs if you don't have
current ones or finally you might gather
feedback on early ideas copy for your
webpage or app and particular features
that users may want this would just be
concept testing a stakeholder map is
another necessity that can help you
think about all the players related to
your business or your industry for
example the stakeholder map for the
SuperDuper shopping app would look like
this notice that this map includes
internal stakeholders such as the user
and external stakeholders like the
suppliers and specialists you can
imagine building out particular features
from recommendations of a nutritionist
or allergist these specialists might
play a role in recommending foods to
particular users based on their dietary
restrictions their dietary goals or
their cooking habits this last activity
is another great way to get perspective
on the industry you can check out
competitors apps or websites to get a
sense for what they're doing this can
help you figure out what's happening in
your current space or industry and you
can also analyze how is your approach
different from these others is it a
subset of features or is it marketing
efforts you can also see particular UI
elements or design elements and flows
that appeal to you and others that you
might want to avoid whatever methods you
choose you should make sure that you
summarize your findings from the
activities these findings should be on
your mind and on the minds of anyone on
your team as you go into the next stage
of the design sprint